let's bring in Texas Republican
Congressman Tony Gonzalez now
Congressman thank you so much for
joining us this is a crisis you know all
too well but the numbers seem to be
climbing getting worse and worse 9,000 a
day they're coming through storm drains
continue to make this this dangerous
Journey even though the White House is
apparently sending the message do not
come but you've got I mean take into
account that the known Goda alwayss as
our reporters are reminding us um this
does not include those numbers of
migrants that are coming in that we see
them Crossing and they're not
apprehended what are people all over
this country supposed to make of what is
happening right
now uh thank you for having me Sandra uh
everything this border crisis touches
turns to Ash whether it's in Eagle Pass
whether it's in El Paso whether it's in
New York City Chicago La it does not
matter small towns big cities all of it
turns to Ash and we know what the
problem is and thankfully you Fox
network has been showing this over and
over again uh this is what's happening
on the ground in in uh Eagle Pass today
they will the the mayor will issue an
emergency declaration because he is
completely over over overwhelmed in El
Paso uh 800 miles which also are is in
my district 800 miles away in El Paso
right now there's nearly 6,000 people in
custody a facility that can hold 2500
people now holds 4,000 people there is
no end in sight we know what the problem
is now we need Solutions the solution is
we got to put down our political pin and
we got to come together because America
depends on it it Congress needs to fix
this the president needs to fix this but
enough with the blame game now it's time
for Solutions well mayor Adams you
mentioned this is a crisis everywhere
all over the country no longer just
affecting border communities in border
states mayor Adams here in New York City
he's ordered all City agencies to cut 5%
from their budgets by November to help
pay for this crisis here he is and the
governor of New York singing the blue
lose over all
this I spoke to the president earlier
this
year and shared our concerns that was
the last time we spoke with the
president we need an emergency
declaration we need to be properly
funded this is just wrong what we're
doing to New York City residents
immigration is a federal problem it
calls for a federal solution we need
your help do something but these are the
very city and state officials who
declared this Sanctuary status all
migrants welcome now they're placing
blame on the federal
government yeah it's it's all fun and
games until the crisis hits your city no
amount of money can can get us out of
this out of this crisis you can't throw
money at this problem to solve it you
can increase the level of capacity to
solve it it's pretty easy to solve what
you have to do is stop playing the blame
game you got to enforce the laws that
are already on the books meaning this we
should sege immigration judges to the
border and we should get people's cases
heard in days days not years and if they
do not qualify for Asylum which nine out
of 10 of them don't you send them back
to the country of origin that is what
you do you also increase the number of
border patrol agents that are on the
ground and you pay them more it's not a
it's not a difficult problem every
presidency has had to do this whether it
was President Trump President Obama
President Bush or President Clinton it's
time for President Biden to do the exact
same thing and by the way you're hearing
from the the New York city and state
officials who are who are you know
regretting that they can't handle this
problem uh while they're dealing with a
much smaller number of migrants mind you
while it's a huge problem here then that
than those border communities um compare
the large number of migrants Crossing
into Texas versus the small number who
have been busted these big cities
congressmen and you're looking at 1.8
million into Texas since April 2022 1.8
million congressmen 35,000 while it's
still a big number pales in comparison
that have been busted the sanctuary
cities final question to you Congressman
what is this like for for the people in
those communities who are at Ground Zero
for this crisis can they can they stand
it
anymore what's moral we yeah those of us
that live and work along the border are
terrorized and we have had enough and
we're tired of of of pointing fingers at
who's the blame we just want this crisis
to go away and and I will say this look
Congress has a role to play in this as
well we can't just be beating up the
administration for doing nothing
congress Republicans Democrats members
of the house and members of the Senate
need to come together to have sensible
solutions that solve the problem part of
that is focusing on legal immigration
those that want to come over and work
and do the do it the right way that so
many Americans have done before we
should promote that and we should find
real solutions and those of those that
those that do not do that and enter
illegally or on a terrorist watch list
should immediately be sent back I think
we can do both but it takes takes bold
leadership and I think Now's the Time
whether it's a small city or a big city
everybody's overwhelmed and I asked that
question because of the massive amount
of migrants that you all are handling in
those areas uh and you compare it to San
Diego for example where they have now
declare declared an emergency a disaster
emergency situation there they have a
mere 2,000 Asylum Seekers comparatively
to what the Border towns are dealing
with and leaders there are saying that
every eer mergency room is at capacity
in San Diego County and the homeless
shelters are full Congressman appreciate
you joining us thank you thank you for
having me S